the biden administration planning on
putting illegal migrants under house
arrest in baltimore and houston instead
of detaining them axios reporting nearly
180 000 migrants are currently in those
programs being introduced to save a
quick buck joining us now to react is
florida congresswoman kat kamik member
of the house homeland security
committee first off let's talk about
this for a second because when you look
at the binding administration they're
celebrating you know this this whole new
cheaper alternative to detention but i
want to know what your solutions are
because it seems like the biden
administration just thinks that they can
catch them and then house them for free
and it's taken care of
well my solution my solution is simple
follow and enforce the laws that are
currently on the books
we have a situation that is a crisis
because of the policies of the biden
administration
we have people who are getting ankle
monitors but then cutting them off as
soon as they get to their final
destination within the u.s if we enforce
the laws on the books and said no you
aren't able to come here illegally you
are not welcome here illegally then we
would actually be in a situation where
we wouldn't even be having this
discussion so i think it's really simple
build the wall enforce the laws on the
books enforce title 42 and the mpp
policy but we've seen that this
administration is more intent on
executing on a political agenda than
actually following the laws
congresswoman this to me
looks like another way for the biden
administration to disperse migrants
throughout the country they got a lot of
flack for the secret flights so now
they're doing it this way it seems like
the effect is the same putting migrants
away from the border and into
communities right now it's in baltimore
and in houston how soon before this
comes to a city or community near you
well it's already happening you know
every town in america is a border town
and i have been on countless flights
where there have been migrants with
paperwork they had just come across the
border and they're being sent all over
the country and of course we see in
cities like new york and other places in
california you don't even have to prove
citizenship to vote so it makes you
wonder what are the motivations of this
administration where they are blatantly
breaking the law subverting the law and
sending these people all across the
country we know we have over 1.7
million people come across our borders
apprehended just last year the drugs the
crime it's all a contributing factor to
the rising crime and issues that we are
having in every single community across
america yeah i mean it's happening 20
minutes from where i live but we want to
move on to this now liberal's beloved
policy is shielding an illegal immigrant
who was charged with drawing swastikas
from fifth deportation this guy was
arrested for the first time in 2006. he
was then deported in 2006 2007 2014
2017. i mean is this just purely the
lack of enforcement as to why these
people keep getting back in
yeah you know it is it's a lack of
enforcement but it's also the draw it's
the magnet here it's the the message
that has been sent from this
administration that they do not intend
to enforce the laws on the books across
the board you have so-called bail reform
which is putting dangerous criminals
right back on the streets there's no
enforcement for violent uh crimes
there's no enforcement for major drug
crimes this is what is drawing people
here saying well listen the the
trafficker in chief in the white house
he doesn't really care what's going on
they're focused on a social justice
warrior agenda that is all about free
handouts and poverty programs to trap
people
that's the magnet and so i think we need
to get serious about again the basics
build the wall secure the border enforce
the laws on the books have our law
enforcement's backs right now we're
seeing cases across the country where
illegals can sue our law enforcement
departments if they try to enforce the
law it's completely backwards we've got
to get our handle on this because if we
don't we're going to lose our country as
we know it it is shocking to me that the
left the alleged party of tolerance
bends over backwards to shield this guy
who commits the most anti-semitic of
anti-semitic acts but that's what we are
as where we are right now finally
congresswoman president biden facing
mounting pressure to roll back covet
restrictions after governors a four
democrat run states drop masking in
schools congresswoman you are in the
halls of congress every day
how much of a reaction is this to the
fact that oh no it seems that democrats
too the voters do not like mass mandates
we better do something as a democratic
party or we're going to get wiped come
november
yeah you know the hypocrisy of the left
really knows no bounds i i walk around
the halls of congress every day and see
my democrat colleagues without masks uh
socializing in groups i see them uh you
know avoiding the the so-called rules
that they have in place but as the
minute of the camera comes on oh my
goodness they gotta throw a mask on
their face they see this as a political
issue at this point that they are losing
and if we know anything about the left
it's about dependency and control and
they'll do anything they can to follow
the polling numbers they see this as an
issue where oh my gosh voters are
actually starting to hate this policy we
better change course we know it was
never about the science it was never
about keeping people or our kids safe
and that's why they're changing because
they know now that they are going to
lose on this issue so it again it's the
hypocrisy of the left and up here in
washington dc we're seeing where they
don't even follow their own guidance so
glad to see it's going yep exactly okay
congresswoman kamik thank you so much
for your time and getting up early with
us this morning we appreciate it hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now